you've been a victim of almost a victim
of the casting couch you said at one
point in your career you were very I
don't know where you were at in your
career some producer invited you to hear
it it was my first audition ever oh my I
had never I was I had just turned 19 I
might have still been 18 I had never
been on out for an audition I asked this
modeling agent if she heard of anything
like I was going to give this acting
thing a try she said yep go to this
guy's house it's on Saturday at 9:00
tattoo all of your auditions were done
at the little foggy garden so 9 p.m. oh
my god Oh a date yeah 9 p.m. there
should be a law against that right I
mean but but you would think your agent
or somebody why didn't have an agent but
you think somebody would have thought
she had a clue either this is what they
do and the guy's a big deal and he's
famous it was a very big deal and it is
still a big deal so on a Saturday night
at nine o'clock you go over to audition
for a film yeah and and and how does
that play out what happened I knocked on
the door and he opened up the door and
he was in his pajamas are you barefoot
first of all why do guys think they're
gonna like like why do you guys think a
showing your dick to someone it's gonna
turn it's embarrassing when any guy
thinks they're sexy at all
sexy guy should not act as though their
physical being is in any way tempting
that can't be a good look on any love
and by the way I just like want it clear
I mean I don't know Robin do you like we
don't want to see you just pull out your
dick no that's exactly right so you go
to the guy's house yeah it's Saturday
night and I'm sure your and here he
answers the door in the pajamas do you
see yeah turn around and say I should
have I didn't pajamas not a good look on
a man no no and but he was he had a very
healthy ego he felt very good about
himself there was some kind of music
playing in the house music never good
cold marble and crystal and then we sat
down and we started talking he said very
close to me that was strange
the drinking bothered me
I was like this is doesn't feel right I
kept kind of saying as he was asking me
questions about me I said I've never
done this so just tell me like I have
these pages do you want me to read these
pages and he was like no no no no this
is I'm just gonna we're just gonna talk
and then at one point he put his hand on
my knee and that's when I just went ooh
and I it's crazy and girls talk about
this where you just go blank like you
don't know what to do but I left I don't
even know how I got out of the house but
I left and I that's amazing driving my
yeah cuz it would have ended really
badly but I was driving my Ford Fiesta
that I was renting like up Laurel Canyon
and I was so angry with myself that I
didn't say something and I was like why
I'm not that kind of girl like why did I
not tell him to go [ __ ] himself like it
made me so angry you know why because in
the moment if you're a decent human
being
even you can't believe what's happening
to you yeah and you feel like you should
be polite yeah it's weird and then
afterwards you go why am I so [ __ ]
polite exactly am I such a good boy or
good girl like while you're looking
people get like murdered because they're
polite there's yeah there's like books
about how like most people would rather
not be impolite and and keep themselves
out of mortal danger right then
potentially like hurt someone else's
feelings yeah which is crazy it took me
eight years for this thing to come full
circle because he offered me a job
oh and I'm I went purely just to have my
moment where he said nice to meet you
and I said no we've met before he had no
recollection of it and his producing
partner was standing right next to him
and he was embarrassed which by the way
it shows you how many women he did it to
he doesn't remember like it was not a
one-off that's insane
that is insane the amount they numbers
so you mean literally he eat now you're
famous yeah had no idea I get Charlize
Theron in a movie yeah you walk in and
you finally said no you met me and
here's what happens and I went down the
list I said it was at 9:00 p.m. on a
Saturday at your house you were wearing
pajamas I went
what had my moment what did you say he
said wow I do not remember that yeah I
bet he does I don't remember that
conveniently I forgot oh my god